I've actually talked them most of the
people that you know you ever did want
you know I've had the privilege of being
able to talk to Bill Clinton I've had
the privilege of talking to other
politicians I've had the privilege of
talking to many great Nobel Prize
winning scientists I actually haven't
found that many barriers to talking with
the people I want to talk to so I don't
know that there's one person that would
really be burning who I haven't been
able to get to talk to and have a
conversation with so I'll pass on that
question I don't know
oh I think the question each of us is
how we going to make the world a better
place when we die how is the world in
small and big ways and you know could be
as as local in communal is you know I
raise great kids I you know led this boy
scout a Girl Scout Troop and you know
was very important for these kids
development to you know I completely
transform their you know this part of
American society or world society or
this village is better because of it I
think if we spend times trying to think
of how we would write our obituary and
what we would want a row bitch ooh ooh
la Mosca roll bitch ooh Airy ought to
start he died with seven billion dollars
well if that isn't the way you want your
obituary to start off with then you
ought to think about how you're making
the world better you know if you've got
a lot of either intellectual or
financial or other resources question is
how you best deploy them so that
tomorrow things will be better than they
are